good morning everybody I am Sam Lee
hammer and joining me today is Rob
handler I don't know why Mike oh hello
test test good morning everyone today is
gonna be a wonderful day I would say
we're gonna be playing some God of War
we're playing through the first 90
minutes so yes yes and no on that we
figured just recently kind of last night
that the first 30 minutes we're actually
not going to show cuz we kind of feel
like there's you know this game is very
heavy-handed and spoilers you know each
person is different we're gonna do our
best not to show significant spoilers so
there's kind of one in the beginning
first 30 minutes 45 minutes that we want
to avoid so you're kind of getting just
the first essence of like what this game
is about like puzzles combat all that
stuff so yeah it's the early couple
hours of the game is what we'll try to
show gotcha
to try to avoid I guess some of the like
setting in the beginning I imagined a
lot of cutscenes a story setting going
on yeah you know absolutely it's gonna
be fun don't want to ruin that moment
for you guys alright so I'm gonna switch
the gameplay we're gonna jump right into
it mm-hmm that's the button up the
gameplay I'll just tab more so you can
hear the amazing wilderness environment
if you guys want the game audio just say
any time to shout us out in the chat I
think it should be good now but so so
this is a spoiler warning guys obviously
if you haven't play golf you haven't
play God over yet if you don't want to
know anything about the game you want to
go blind abort abort mission now but if
you're excited and you want to see what
this game is about we're going in
yeah and first off this game is so
freaking gorgeous it is hands-down the
best console the title to date it is
just the absolute best looking game I've
seen in the console have you been
playing it for K so we're lucky enough
to have we're playing on pro here I have
one of ps4 just vanilla original at home
it still looks good no matter what no
matter what ps4 you have our own it
looks
regardless this is on piecework pro this
is in 1080p I have been playing at 4k I
have a 4k TV at home and we have one in
the office I mean it does look better on
a ps4 Pro on 4k obviously yeah but it
still it's still gonna rock your world
it's such an awesome looking game yeah
to preface what's going on right here I
know we mentioned that we cut so this is
about 30 45 minutes into the game
the the scenes so far is that your your
Kratos your son's name is art Reyes
you're a traces mom your wife died and
you did a burial of her here and now
your ultimate goal as of right now is to
get her ashes to the top of the peak
because that's what she wanted
yes so that's what you're doing and so
you're cruising now to try to make your
way to the top now this game is set in
with Norse mythology so it's like a
departure from all that Greek mythology
of round three right and the other games
there's like some PSP games also now I
took a mythology class in high school
no nice so I have to say Norse mythology
is way more hardcore than Greek
mythology yeah I can see that yeah like
having played I'm close to the end of
beating this game and yeah there's some
sure that happens
[Laughter]
bad boy dcx yes this is live people
they're trying to survive - oh let me do
swings you hmm I know this is always
something that people want yes somehow
find a way to talk over what they're
talking about in terms of I'm a little
bit for sure here's another cool thing
so last night there was an update for
this game previously it was just for HUD
I for one like the more immersive
experience meaning less HUD during
combat when you're non-combat your HUD
will naturally fade with normal mode but
they added more stuff so this is pretty
neat so what you can do I don't know why
I can't do it right now
dialogue and prevent preventing me from
doing it but I'll show in a second it's
really cool like games
desperation games should take away from
something like this or incorporate more
off bad boy DCX the game is not out
right now the game is going to be out
Tet I think they'll preload time is at 9
yeah I think for certain territories
territories yes so we have access to the
game earlier in the embargo in up this
morning so that's how we're playing she
can kind of already gauge it this is a
puzzle here but let me go back to this
HUD did I think this is very neat so why
isn't it letting me do this it's odd I
was just able to do it I'm so sorry Rob
maybe because you're in the middle like
a call to action here I guess
so maybe finish some stuff and then yeah
anyway we'll come back to come back to
it that's really weird I was just like
loading this up earlier and I was able
to do it yeah we're doing a little
puzzle here obviously mm-hmm so like
this game is like very much inspired by
and they've even admitted to it which is
fine did they've they've taken away a
lot of like puzzles and aspects of like
Last of Us and I mean like other Naughty
Dog type games like Uncharted yeah well
that makes sense
the game does director had done I can't
hit his name Corey yeah Corey bar log he
worked on the Tomb Raider reboot also he
directed God war two when we did did
some cool things to the Tomb Raider
reboot and then came back to that war
with this and I think from playing the
Tomb Raider reboot I feel like there was
a lot of those elements too with puzzles
and QuickTime events and cool stuff a
good yeah absolutely
I'm very uncharted the Tomb Raider
reboot felt very uncharted to me mm-hmm
so yeah like tons of stuff and it's all
great like even so our trace trace your
son you'll go around and find
discoveries and it's kind of neat it's
all in the vein of like his narrative so
it's like
oh he'll talk about a beast you kill
maybe like dad was a badass and he did
this with his axe but and then as well
as give a little few tips and the tips
are decent so you can see there a lot of
wolves typically hunting packs and will
try to surround their prey father should
keep try to keep them in front of him
his voice is quite manly oh for sure yes
got like a tinny low tone to it that's
like very unnatural which is great
worshiping the gods regards care nothing
for them men should not pray to monsters
by the way your axe is the coolest
freaking thing yeah and it never gets
old the actually so cool reminds me of
that's a very Thor thing yeah oh for
sure for sure
and as we know Thor is North Scott Norse
gods oh wait I forgot something if you
guys are asking questions in chat I will
be addressing some of them I just wanted
to I'm trying to give some breathing
room to actually just enjoy the game a
little bit here so you'll constantly be
doing this - in this game we're like
okay oh I screwed I know there's tons of
hidden stuff in like every area of the
game so like even right now I missed
that I noticed that there's a chest do
you want to get
over there axe to me
cyborg man says I imagine that you talk
to yourself like this all the time when
you play games are gonna be weird I
probably wouldn't have a roommate at
that point for some reason this game
reminds me of writing Zordon or The Last
of Us
yes yeah the settings are kind of like
rustic like wear and tear of you know I
don't know like almost like cavemen like
a tire and something right like that's
very horizon for sure yeah definitely so
the other other thing too is the game
maybe not right now but like right now
I'm like knocking down this chain
because I might come back because a lot
of this as the more you play the more
you'll see areas that you can't quite
get to now and they and the game hints
that you're probably gonna want to come
back here so knocking down chains and
making it easier for you to like get
back up opposed to doing that whole
puzzle again have pretty often
nice one thing that God were always it
was really like expansive environments
and it's cool to see them stick with
that you've got the better consoles
bigger environments bigger spaces
officer Locke the tree she wishes for
her pyre why'd you do that
come no looking back now moment of
contemplation therefore Kratos someone
asked if it's the same voice actor from
the previous kata Wars I don't know that
answer
should I do a little research you could
I know the voice actor of Kratos is I
think he's from like Stargate like the
show I don't know I don't know what
other work he's done but I did look up
the kid he the kid hasn't done anything
worth noting I don't think but it's
interesting is that the kid the voice
actor uh betrayus is looks exactly the
same like that's the one modeling or I
wonder if I even did like motion capture
like harder person okay I in in you to
him and I can sir your name he's asked
if this is a big replay factor my mark
um you'd be surprised I think we're
gonna have never get into combat
it's it's not necessarily replay factor
it's that this game is freaking gigantic
it's to just to play the campaign or
story stuff alone it's like 30 hours
like minimum that's not including other
stuff there are people in office Peter
Brown who review the game like he's
still doing stuff
despite like you there's just tons of
side stuff to do that's all worthwhile
and there sends a story and lore to be
found like this game is surprisingly
gigantic it's not your like typical
blockbuster like a tower one thing that
Peter knows in his review that I was
interested in or something that piques
my interest was that those expanded
puzzles and sighs besides little side
quests and things never feel old like
they never they don't get stale
yeah so you do lock on so I can lock on
to him right-click on this they do it so
the skill treats to like you it starts
off slow but the abilities you get with
your axe and your movement and all these
runes with your stuff you start becoming
so badass right now okay he throws down
oh and that's the thing you level up him
as well so he starts getting even more
like he'll start choking guys and like
will stun enemies for you to then like
come up and finish them off it's oh oh
what's up oh hey frozen like a mannequin
so you can do that right and then I can
like so I can use my axe to stun this
guy cuz I have two winds up
it's my are two throw will stun him like
that and I can worry and like about this
guy and then come back what up
nice I like the stuns
it's nice been a multipass can you deal
with different enemies right or waves of
enemies okay let me see if I can do this
now in the middle of a fight there we go
yes okay I'm excited so this is really
cool so immersive again turns everything
off so you're not seeing any prompts
whatsoever on the screen now up until
last night they it got it's not
frustrating but one of the things is
like gameplay notifications so it's like
anything I pick up it'll give me a
little menu or HUD I'll be okay this is
what you picked up and immersive it
doesn't even do that so you have to go
into the menu and it's kind of like
tedious now you can turn select where
you can select things turn off and on so
like I think a cool setup is like
alright I'll leave those notifications
on it's when I pick up stuff you know
what it is I know what it is and then
they also added this touch the touch pad
so like I can turn on yet that's a cool
use for the touch panel right why it's
really neat so like so so say this is
what I want right so now it's so funny
now what I'm actually playing I can
still do the immersive but say I'm lost
or I need to know even threat indicators
hey I can turn that off so this this
will let you know if there's a guy
coming up behind you yeah but you can
hear it like it's actually the game is
without having those prompts you can
actually hear dudes come from behind you
are at Reyes will let you know but
anyways so like touch pad so now my
compass why isn't it doing it now this
is tutorial oh that's all right cool go
away oh man you dodged that skillet why
you let your son handle it doing it this
is not going well Oh Rob it's okay we'll
figure it out it's cuz you're it's fine
because you're in the middle yeah it's
probably yeah it's probably it you know
the settings will probably reconfigure
after this is over
so yeah now their interest introducing
like more enemy types
so our traces bone arrow will stun the
thing about stun is you'll get
executions out of them so if I use my
fists I'm stunning him you can't see the
bar and I'll believe it on so you can
actually see so you see the meter below
at the red that's the Sun meter and then
the top of its health so nice if I beat
this guy up and get stunned and have our
trash chute him when he gets max then I
do that execution status oh that's nice
which is you know a little cinematic
fight a little cinematic and like if you
need a breather and like you're you know
you get kind of immunity during those
right like no one can actually like deal
damage on you
yeah we're just nice yeah I don't use
block enough should be blocking all
those now my health is really no that's
great but you gotta look around your
environment because what's the health
those green gems here we go speaking to
what somebody earlier said about replay
factor I think that it's hard you know
with single player games in generally
once you've exhausted everything there
is
it's sometimes hard to go back and if it
be personally to replay games in general
but I think if this game is gonna have
that problem I think it'll probably
still be fun even after they finished
yeah what you were saying earlier yeah
right like there's a lot of side stuff
so people like some people that I know I
can see the complaint that maybe because
it's kind of just the same execution for
each there's only one execution for the
most part for one enemy type yeah but I
still enjoy it after the hundredth time
it's a damn good execution I like that
these expert Perry's on the flame flame
guy over there
well user can really this is really
getting really cool abilities to like
parry back stuff mm-hmm but you can't do
it quite yet so I'm saying like
eventually kratos becomes so badass with
the abilities and stuff someone say I
enjoyed that part yeah lumpiness
feelings all right trust me there there
are some executions that are so freakin
cool I was by myself miles oh yeah you
were that's what I see I was kind of
joking before but I knew yeah there's
this somewhere it's like there's like an
enemy type that's like there's one
execution where it's trying to get away
and you like bring it back this looks so
cool like after like a really annoying
enemy is just like giving you a hard
time like it's there's some
gratification they're a cyborg man
earlier asked why did Kratos become
depressed and I feel like this is like
Kratos was always depressed he like from
the beginning he did a lot of messed-up
stuff he did a lot of bad stuff he was a
bad boy yeah and he did a lot of bad
things and even after starting a new
family he still feels real bad so the
other cool thing is that you start
finding at Reyes is like very
well-versed in like the Norse mythology
and like he's able to read Kratos was
not right because he's Greek but his mom
and your wife taught him the whole bunch
so he's he's kind of like your
through this new world he does like a
lot her helps at the storytelling and
then really interesting when I guess I
liked that he didn't know that his son
could read those things it was kind of
like this moments like dad were what are
you doing
he's a very distant father mm-hmm I see
a scene are you playing ps4 Pro yes we
are yeah so again I really want this was
not this has not been going well but
it's cuz this is all still died of
tutorial so now it should work
mr. touchpad is just broken
doesn't make any sense why is this it
doesn't make any sense just trying to
give you it out maybe we don't have that
hood mmm are you sure to hang everything
on and then turning it I don't freak and
get it I said I was this was working
earlier maybe it's just like because
it's what's up I love bringing it
bringing it back and having it do damage
like on the return I think this is just
still early on where it's still kind of
tutorial stuff so it's not like me do
that
that's my only reasoning there dad of
the year 2018 I don't know we'll see
uh-oh retro so this is this is the
introduction to like the first ability
you get like with runes right so runes
or things you you get to like a heavy
and light and you get to upgrade them
and put them on your axe so this one
will stun enemies and that has a
cool-down but these get progressively
more and more awesome something I think
that has gotten progressively more
awesome is greatest is beard mm-hmm this
game would not be good without it no
it's like way cooler than his previous
look okay yeah can you raise your head
for me
so this yeah you hold l1 give me my ax
you need to have your ax in order to do
it that will double splined and stun
guys Oh
your son was impressed he was super
impressed
move move you're angry I mean I never
looked up who his voice actor is and I
was I was hoping Bob Jones our resident
researcher would come through but he's
here yet or you might not be R at all
today I'm gonna look it up there are
clay once on how far we are into this
this is about 45 minutes into the game
let's tops 45 minutes I want to say this
games hard to gauge time because he cost
us you can find yourself I'm not losing
track well just merely exploring a lot
like it everyone will play this game
differently like you can you can go
about every nook and cranny because the
environment is so worthwhile like
there's it's jam-packed
it was a new actor wasn't the same voice
actor as previous kratos's it sounds
different
some use that ability here
Oh Oh these fire enemies are pretty
awesome what yeah yeah they are I think
I don't know if they're on fire some oh
they are they know but you know you're
right like that guy's clearly utilizing
it oh there's definitely times we like
that was back there seems like he has a
fire yeah you're right no you're right
you're right yeah I just know that you
can definitely set these two dudes on
fire and they don't like that would you
recommend uncapped FPS or 4k xxx yes
that's a super good question I played a
live this game at home 4k at 30 and it
looks really good and then a John Luke
at work here recommended trying it at 60
and I kind of want to say on capped at
60 is like better just make sense the
difference in in resolution is pretty
minimal and like to have to combat be at
60 frames it feels a whole lot better
like right now I mean this obviously
isn't 4k it was 1080 but like I would I
would prefer like the frame rate for
sure because it doesn't dip
significantly but like you can't nothing
is ever gonna be distracting in that 34
K mode but like I don't know sometimes
it was chuggy
just you just notice it when you see 60
like you think about it
dammit
so the boy factor for this credo this is
Christopher judge who was best known as
TLC from Stargate yeah I was sorry yes
wait I could be wrong he did the first
looking at that IMDB yeah no I I could
be wrong here and he's did the first
greatest but not the other two
or he was over he must have done the
other ones own yeah it's all okay well
cool trace do it shoot them
[Applause]
James esse he had that he had that
douchebag goatee before he did and it
was very that was like very 2005 the
actor no the crater oh he did
I didn't even yeah he had he had like a
shaped up goatee in the first one huh
actually oh it is christopher Judge
thank you guys thank you
it's finding me I wasn't fine super
definitive answers on Google right away
and I just want to go too far in the
hole there
thank you I wrote a 2005-2013 Kratos is
terrorist Carson Terrence person oh
[Music]
hello hi we're trying to get them out
oh hey hi oh hello hey do you know a
good market around here
see if I can do a parry on this dude
bring it nope that's not it oh it's
definitely not a very happy one
so yeah the timing of the parries if
you're late you get stunned let's do it
he can stun you god that's the one I can
never I'm trying to time it right so I
can get him to stun there it is nice
that was really cool yeah it almost
looks like a sound wave like yeah so
like it's not really spoilery but there
are some abilities that like kind of do
that same aesthetic
yeah like rune abilities and they're so
freaking awesome I slowed most stuff
somebody asked earlier does he only get
the axe or does he have to get different
weapons like it's just the axe just the
axe that's definitely different than the
old cutter worse we got to use different
things but the axe does so much
versatile axe yeah like it's it seems
simplistic here but a it ramps up as you
build oh yeah yeah what you what the axe
can do never ceases to amaze
there it is cows God says the axes wick
and I still miss the chain blade so just
a little bit
like oh man
like it starts the more you play them
they're more you have them like I always
keep forgetting that at Reyes I can tell
to shoot oh my god oh no I was so that's
that's what it looks like when you die
that's so sad they make him give me make
the Sun sad oh yeah they write that
always gets me because I think of about
scene in the Lion King or Mufasa dies
and Simba don't act like that didn't get
you when you work I don't remember
oh come on I'm I don't have a heart
no but that's what do you say that cuz
that's probably the first time you mean
you know it sound like that's the only
movie that's done it but yet that's what
you remember oh my god that was the
first time I think I like lost it your
parents had to like call me I was like
five years old and I was like watching
the or five or six I was in my room
watching the VHS and I started crying
[Music]
now do it that's the one so again I'm
playing on immersive mode so it's like
you only get like those prompts you can
see them shimmering I think it's the way
to play it like me it makes the combat
difficult but like start noticing like
you never really let your guard down you
got it yeah be a badass always damn it
like that was like that that was really
badass right yeah no but that was like
you know even when you're getting white
up like that when he turns his head and
it like comes towards the camera like it
yeah like little things like that or
just wow I don't know it's very
impressive [ __ ]
this isn't going so well I'm embarrassed
I just miss all my other abilities from
others say there it is so he drop some
health so I can get that now and prolong
that oh cool more guys are coming that's
fine yeah have one coming damn it
crisp anyone asks is this game reveal
what happened after the events of God of
War three bonus event if I actually
don't know about a war 3 - so I don't
know like if if you play those games
you'll sure you'll I don't know is it is
there is the story I guess
they have to set the stage for this in
the introduction of the game I haven't
played it I haven't played the very
opening yet so I can't speak to it but
um they have to explain how the heck he
ends up here I don't know at some point
yeah that's I don't know I mean I'd
rather Rob trying to be coy I am very
much I mean if you're gonna play this
game
yeah don't listen to me
oh yeah
they're making I think so I see some
people on the twitch shop making
comparisons The Last of Us and uncharted
and saying that this copies it I don't
think it's a copy of those games
necessarily I think it takes what those
games did the best and definitely
utilized some of those things right side
doesn't seem like a direct copy to me
and that's what good games do right they
recognize great aspects of other games
then they try to do it even better you
know mm-hmm oh yeah definitely like this
this game really sets the bar in a way
like it's just so freakin awesome on all
fronts you're honest like alright cool I
got through that
we doing on time and you punch people in
this game you can punch people
you sure can now we got like another
however cool yes we got some time before
I I was so freakin cool the axe is so
freaky yeah every bit like I love how it
like makes the noise is on the return
like anything ting ting ting ting like
hittin all this stuff it's very much
Thor's hammer like that scene in um
Ragnarok right reason uh he's in dr.
strangers places like go Spurs hammer is
oh yes just tearing up the whole house
that is probably the best one of my
favorite scenes yeah actually that was
really funny really well done
yeah Oh anyone turn it or turn this up a
little bit I can't okay hold on just a
little bit so you hear some stuff here
sounds like my grandma the same song she
sang me chuckles she's saying dinner is
ready grandma so this this any type you
the reverb I missed I'm saying it if I
if I throw my ax when she is you can
kind of see when she's got like the glow
of poison magic she'll dodge my ax
though right there see so you have to
have a trace stun owner and then you're
able to go to town oh yeah like what are
you playing on right now
Oh difficulty level this is just normal
I believe another one opens up once you
beat the game I think super super super
guards super super super super hard this
game's hard already man I like the lab I
find this game challenging in that like
you'll get skills unlocked and you click
alright cool I may use this skill on
this person and that's cool maybe isn't
the best choice like you find yourself
really changing up your play style like
close to long-range sorry so some basis
sounds like scooby-doo giggling evil
enemy play all the little scoops now
yeah
these are always like the enemy enemies
want to get rid of first is they're so
freaking annoying when like you're also
tossed other types I saw this somebody
say this not in our comment section just
now but it was on John Luke's history
yata war apparently every year Sony has
had an exclusive rank over a 90 on
Metacritic every single year I don't
know III back check that some I probably
will want to go back to fact check that
but that's pretty crazy like it's this
game isn't hard I just suck been sick
burn sick where somebody asked me last
random but somebody asked in chat last
week if what my favorite controller is
and they were expecting me to say some
type of like pro controller or something
and I said with rock candy controllers
because they're pretty I have no idea
what the troll you're talking about
yeah it's like it's next box one third
party controller and they have a good
crystal case and it's really pretty not
the best performance and then somebody
asked me well why don't you go for a
controller that's actually really good
and I'm like the controllers not gonna
make me better
I'm not that good
Jesus I'd say the three Xbox 360 is
probably my favorite controller for the
ps4 Razer made a that's X yeah those
guys have such hard swings hard swings
whoa like yeah like they're like you
can't deal heavy damage yeah yeah I
can't parry those you can see the red
glowing circle like you you just have to
dodge can't do anything about it I was
gonna say one of the the ps4 controller
that I want to get is it's the Razer I
want to see it's like a guide it's
called guide you or something and it's
kind of shaped like an Xbox controller
like I'm not gonna lie they they totally
were like yeah those controllers have
better air ergonomics so we're gonna
make this ps4 controller look like an
Xbox controller
so paring and dodging is super important
in this game yeah most definitely
not like an afterthought Oh No and this
this guy is all about the dodge and some
of the previous cata wargames
peirong was a skill that you had but it
wasn't necessarily important or super
important you can still beat the games
out really dodging oh come on
dang it
all right am i yeah you got the right
idea the resident yes no that was
definitely like a preload like he's like
get another up there they're really mad
at us does a bunch of them pretty much
what you got boy what this is what he
says let's try it
see I was looking at what oh my god
surprise attacks pretty much oh he's mad
sun's mad so one cool thing is you can
totally like push guys off cliffs and
stuff which is the very satisfying and
can get the job done pretty quick fully
bass does this game still have set
pieces that are huge huge huge set
pieces that are huge yeah absolutely
yeah I mean yeah you imagine if it did
definitely I don't think I mean that's
so that's what these games are all about
you know yeah epicness so these are
awesome it's little puzzles there's like
three I think they're called runes as
well
you gotta find in the world oops
or seals excuse me and then you can
unlock that chest there's one more
earlier you said people might try and
Rob us we encountered man you stay out
of it
you stay out of the way
oh nice
let's go so you can poke your shell - oh
yeah definitely I shall show the skill
that it was oh hey that's funny I feel
like I would totally do that or do that
combo rot so that just seems like so
much fun yeah that's a when you son you
son one and then you can go in like yeah
right like that slipper
absolutely like he's like that's what
they want you'd really to do is like
like use your axe a few times and then
charge it the bigger guys I always try
to like business myself but like damn it
it seems like some are easier to handle
it without the axe actually yeah can you
block up your shields yeah like with
that parrying you'll see the Proms
oh yes it's not even there interesting
enough guys welcome to GameSpot stream
we're playing some God at war I've been
here every Thursday now my high school
didn't have a whole lot of awesome stuff
but the one cool thing I ever got to do
was take a mythology class look one cool
thing that was really fun so yeah here
is your skill tree the axe the shield
and then the bow as you upgrade your axe
you get to unlock more things so like
for this there's some cool oh and then
the rage mode I haven't shown that yet
will be a cool one to go here um breakin
any enemies block that's pretty useful
oh this is a good one so we're gonna
both this this is like a charged up
heavy attack that is pretty cool kind of
has its own execution as well nice it
does it inflict fro that's a different
under run it's like frost damage as well
yes or no like later on you you get like
more abilities or skills where you can
like yeah deal additional frost or like
get get more frost from like landing
kills or hits excuse me so yes I know
for that but yeah definitely
this thing ROI cuts one here jetseal
said saddened to to how much they
changed the series but I always keep an
open mind so I'll buy this one I guess
he was a big fan of the original god of
War's
and this one is definitely a bit
different mm-hmm hopefully you enjoy it
oh there's one more yes I just the
eternal main man Jake oh sorry if I'm
butchering your name but it does have a
level system or like a skill tree it we
just saw you just were in it yeah those
are the skills there's also a whole
system here with your armor and runes
and what they call enchantments so this
is again earlier on this is within the
first hour you start you know putting a
skill and energy into like you know do I
want more strength do I want more my
runes on what put more power and like
those like cool like abilities I have
which is like this vitality would be
health right yeah like that's a--that's
a rune ability so you can kind of tailor
and butt and buff the skills that you
enjoy the most
yeah you find yourself using the most
yeah and so it champions you tack on you
can't release team here because I don't
have any slots for them but yeah like
you get a new piece of armor and say
that has like a lot of strength but not
so much runic stats well then I can put
I can find an enchantment that will
boost up my runes so you just you just
then have further catering to like your
own stats and then these are the runes
so those are the abilities you just saw
you get heavy and light and then like
another kind of wooden grip which will
do further stuff and then your skills so
there's tons oh there's tons going on
Filipa Mundaka says hey can you give
your axe different effects other than
frost and electric fire and so on
good question this
is just frost for the most part cold
acts
uh heavenly NASSCOM says what is the
link between the previous god award in
the new one Rob didn't want to spoil it
earlier so the link or the length o link
yes
what's the bridge between the two yeah I
don't know yeah what I know about is
it's pretty simple creative Kratos goes
on and starts a new family and then the
one his the mother of his son dies and
that's where this game starts so that's
just like a very basic plot point for
you I don't know if I answered your
question but not yeah it's where we're
at right now
yes dangerous that wind of his dangers
it's like that you have this heavy
attack weight like you can't just music
so you're so vulnerable on come on
recharging yes
Oh get out of your dude boson daddy says
thanks to the stream well then give her
beam yure if you're coming in checking
it out
first on over there he's fine
is he okay so the spotting rage mode
nice okay so this makes you basically
really really really cool yeah you're
pretty cool when this happens but yeah
so depending on the heart and or a
heavier reliatech I have associated with
that will be how quickly a depletes yeah
I want that takes a while to charge that
up to us yeah
minista
Philippe says would it be fair to say
this game soon reminds me Dark Souls in
the combat a little like a little Ward's
of shadows twists in the combat I think
that your pump I mean I think the
dodging and the pairing makes it feel
like that a little bit the rolling
rolling around back and forth but
probably come on probably little
different yeah it's definitely like you
could pull some scenarios I guess yeah I
I think it's just the the pairing and
the dodging that makes it feel like
appear that way yeah some of the boss
fights remind me of Dark Souls yeah
oh here we go later there will be more I
didn't say in the end of God of War
three kratos moves on and start a new
family I said that in the beginning of
this game that's where we we start off
so I wasn't speaking to the end of God
were three I was speaking to the
beginning of this game he loses his wife
yeah it's great
damn right Angela Felipe everything is
dark souls we're not making any serious
comparisons Dark Souls or this is just
you know somebody in the chat made a
comment and I could I just want you know
there's something you could see where he
was coming from in his assessment that
some of these fights seemed like that or
I would like that
no problem Felipe
I see a couple PC gamers in the chat
here and I will say this is the type of
game we got to play on a big TV behind
me Myrtle this fight is mine alone strip
off their meat
he said matter-of-factly oh that was a
transhuman he was human okay what a
father can you play this game on PC no
you cannot it is a ps4 exclusive and to
those who say they want to play it on PC
I mean I want to play this on a big 4k
TV that's what I want to play it on I'm
sure I could hook it up with a PC to 4k
I could probably hook a PC up to a 4k TV
I guess but I don't see what though I'll
just get a ps4 bro
consul hat oh dear God the Pennsy
beggars I'm a piece I'm a huge advocate
for PC gaming I love my PC but some
things are just need to be were there so
trace just killed boy this dude and he
he's just on top of him now off my son
whoa
close your heart to it come then we have
a long journey oh come on why is that
guy gotta ruin the the sentimental
moment I was in my feeling no no this is
that was deep I was not expected yeah
it's it's really awesome where this game
goes what a beautiful moment this I was
talking what sure looks nice wow the
heavy wind up is like I can aboard it if
I even see a guy who's gonna hit me
first that's good you don't get stuck in
it right that's a good choice we want
your shot you're right in the feels
angel seriously I'm in them right now
it's it's awesome this game is so
awesome like that like it yeah it gets
better and better
sorry guy trying to get the last game
that put me like hard in my feelings
like that
basically would name one that got blasts
of us yeah like the last of us that was
a long time ago last of us did that I
replayed it and whenever the remaster
came out you know I don't know actually
the last of us kind of hit me with a lot
of like oh [ __ ] moments but I don't know
if I like cried over the last of us
about like a giraffe scene after like
what you want you know more oh yeah
actually you're right also drafts for my
favorite animals I forgot about that
yeah Josh the best I have a draft
collection you have pet drafts no I have
like a bookshelf like five drafts my
dress I collect them I'm kind of on the
run because I steal them does this game
have grab moves yourself we must find
her way out that's a kind of oh so we're
like this so yeah maybe the game
continues like you know doesn't just
like have those those really emotional
moments I get like it'll continue right
like look at him he's like super he's
just he's he's
here's keep watching go drop the chain
okay
that's rias the Jane okay right
sorry I missed somebody's comment
earlier which is like he's like why'd
you throw that ax at me dad it's fine
let it go you would have killed you we
will go home boy what you give up this
easily so close to the start
wait nope I'm not giving up I can do
this I just have to you know catch my
breath come on oh I'm ready
there's my boy nice close your heart
like me b.o.b hardened the brute killer
just punch punch of box take it out on
pots
I like that those broke yeah it's the
small things like that you're able to
punch pretty much everything in break it
you just gotta be effective in combat a
warrior must not feel for his enemy the
road ahead is long and unforgiving no
place for a boy you must be a warrior
cleaver Greene who are you people and
how long have you been working at
GameSpot who are you people
I'm Sam if you haven't come upon one of
my streams yet I assume on Thursdays I'm
being spot social media one of our
social media producers and I've been
working here for almost a year my one
year is May Rob your turn my turn I'm
about four years video producer Rob does
lots of fun stuff yeah and this guy is
there's only a few characters in this
game but they're all really good pleased
to meet you too father
so your action those trees on the other
side of the bridge the ones with the
white trunks
think the ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ow
there needs to be a cat into the one cat
screech Wow the detail the furs oh and
that's also something to talk about is
that if you haven't noticed she's been
one camera one long tracking camera shot
yeah like it really goes on forever like
I want to say maybe three hours from now
you notice oh they had to do something
or like I love how seamless the
transitions are between the cutscenes
these little cutscenes and actual games
like it was me what made her me and my
brother was one of our best so don't let
nobody else go work on except for us -
you got a handle or special or she'll
wreck beyond fixing I get enhancer for
you right now if it so pleases you son
of a [ __ ] so what's see you you all
right I do not believe you
come boy there's a rune in the shape of
a fork under the grip that was our brand
my brother and me before we split I got
half of it right here ski look you want
to sit up great or not you're up gran I
expect an improvement
is they gave this little troll man like
one long leg one short leg three limbs
that's what it seems like why is he
watching otherwise age his legs are
probably different lengths all right
we're gonna upgrade this axe now you can
upgrade then oh as well now so yeah I
mean says it pretty seems like a pretty
good game I agree that you see what you
were saying about the game just sucks
you in
oh that's when the reason is like you
have a really difficult time putting it
down it's because it's you know it's not
like most games where it's like you can
you know like a game of call dude you're
right 15 minutes and then I you know I'm
done another one another round this is
like you just do it you just find
yourself like two three hours in and
nothing has really slowed down at all
like you're it's hard to stop to be
honest which is great in a way until you
start swinging yourself in the couch
somebody came in said god of interactive
movies
I think that'd be I feel like got a
workout eventually got sort of a bad rap
for having so many of those cinematic
fight scenes but at the time God War
came out I that was actually not
something that was utilized a whole lot
in games and it was pretty cool I
remember I was I was 15 with the first
guy to work came out and remember that
being like oh this is like look how cool
this is it's like an action movie like
you know by like our three I guess that
kind of got stale with some people but
it was one of the first games to utilize
in a really epic way so right now I'm
just getting some armor so here's a cool
one you know with with our trash so I'm
gonna give him this basic fighter fit
we're just going to increase his melee
damage but he'll also like like jump on
enemies back and like choke them nice
is like a more-or-less a stun and like
an advantage for me to like finish off
whatever he's attacking just cool like
he become a trace becomes really really
awesome you start realizing how that's
actually kind of essential like he
becomes a big player and like how you
fight guys okay sell some stuff some
lost toys and what's great oh so soft an
optimist in this case soft and
optimistic those are two really funny
words to put together I consider myself
a pretty soft and optimistic person sure
you know maybe you could say he has a
son that's living now he hasn't killed
him yet miraculously and
uh his his baby mama just died that's
sad and there on this life I don't know
I think like those human elements make
him much more interesting
I don't know he's optimistic though bro
you're on fire ooh the heartbeat
[Applause]
super-government
yeah that's the one thing about this
immersive mode is that's kind of hard to
tell when I have that yeah I don't use
it often so it's okay but when my rooms
so that one ability where I blind people
yeah I'll get an audio cue and that's
back so it's not it's not like totally
you're not totally helpless without it
the HUD indication but I could turn that
on if I wanted to impair these do you
prefer playing in immersive mode like
this yeah I like it a lot more variety
reasons I mean it's also if you know
looks a lot better and I do like it does
make you like more attentive when
playing with like audio cues or
someone's behind you and stuff way more
enjoyable
yeah Moe Montana says is the game worth
$65 right now I would say it's probably
worth every penny given the fact that it
has a super high Metacritic score right
now people are really enjoying it at
least a Sam who had a chance to play and
there's a lot to do in the game there's
a lot of time to spend in the game so
don't have to worry about it being a
super short or anything if you're
watching it and you think it might enjoy
fire worth pick up I think I can do an
upgrade here my schools yeah so as you
can see now I have more skills I can add
to my axe and shield or no just accident
I can do all this here
that's going one I really like is this
one come here's a good question another
good question from Felipe
I've been favoring your questions said
in previous got Awards you fought things
that were larger than life pretty often
did we see a lot of those larger enemies
even if it's on a slightly smaller scale
yep you get some big big badass enemies
later on awesome yep
100 percent that's exciting
people are one thing everything else you
fight until I say stop
we are dead this is a cool thing there's
a lot of cool puzzles with the axe
sizing see here I'm using axe to open up
doors
oops
oh now yeah don't run into spikes
okay I got a oh yeah that's one make
sure because there's GS daily coming up
at 11:00 yes
you guys want stick around I had 11
o'clock we do games daily it's a news
wrap-up show that we do when today
talking about the biggest schemes news
stories of the day so this is like a
cool puzzle where oh [ __ ] yes
Oh trace is the legit son of Kratos we
should believe that anyway no your yeah
Kratos father I thought I had this right
so so you got a do forgot
yes we are playing in 4k right no no no
no no we're playing on ps4 Pro this is a
1080p screen they're streaming in 4k
would take a lot of I don't think you
I'm not gonna say that I don't know if
it's most or not but to me that seems
we'd have to
yeah I I genuinely think I don't think
that's possible yeah I don't think it is
either open but I imagine playing this
in 4k it's pretty amazing it's pretty
freakin cool see like right there he
just said Oh from behind so I don't
necessarily need a prompt oh here we go
I can take this listen for it
so I just got a new ability here the
skill so what if I get a headshot it
flashes and I get like more damage on my
next throw nice buy time it right he
throws it like a different way you can
see yeah yeah yeah it's fun to do
yeah just like wouldn't you nail it
feels really good yeah like next I'm
gonna do more damage awesome yeah it
makes a cool audio chime to please
thanks raspily pay bonuses thanks for
answering my questions friend is I'll
have to poke my head any more often yeah
I come by we stream everyday around this
time oh no no no later actually we
normally do 11 - from 11 to 11:30 I
guess ah daily at 11:30 - one week we
flavor of the of the day flavor of the
week mm-hmm so this week we'll probably
playing more got a war and they'll be
playing more tomorrow right Rob yeah
tomorrow we're gonna play around the
same time I think 9 a.m. Eric and I are
gonna play again to avoid spoilers we'll
be doing like kinda like more mid close
to mid game side quests and stuff so not
only have some of the higher skill tree
stuff yeah like abilities and such yeah
like I don't know if we'll get there
today but there is like a a hub area in
this game with tons of stuff to do
around it has a nice emotional man that
wasn't if there's a nice moment there
where he's like I wanna I want to be
there for my son but I can't I don't
worry either he's like it's a mixture of
things right right to make sure things
like maybe he doesn't want to coddle his
son to be too sentimental or emotional
over the the definitely or maybe he
himself is like can't grieve it he
doesn't want to grief you know Slayer
know probably layers
that's hilarious exactly probably
thinking about the death of his first
wife right that could that could be good
running through his head
like again maybe he just needs to go to
bathroom or something maybe right you
never know what players players
never be little trigger-happy holy crap
you can call the axe back to you oh my
god yeah yep
it's so it's so gratifying Magneto even
still oh cool what will actually end it
all right yeah I DS am out of time
actually yeah we do have another like 10
minutes before we got a trade-off here
Massena if I have a ps4 Pro and a 4k TV
is 4k compatible I see yeah yeah yeah
you should be good yeah please take some
financing with like your your TV set
it's the answer what I alone can never
be right use your knife and trace the
rooms into the sand
something happened
I'm happy with my bra but it is behind
us now
this game looks so good it does things
like that we're like the rocks roll off
when you enter the cave and the rocks
just roll off of the platforms there
yeah little things like that you know
it's being a little things so these guys
are called they're like Odin's Ravens
they're like one of the collectibles so
if you can hear them there's little fun
things you kill
boy boy these tracks a bore maybe not
sure what all fine Kratos with silk on
boy when news like thirty sharp dad yeah
boy I'm a man dad
here we go big guy oh wow that is a big
boy boy
that's a real big boy are you guys gonna
do this
x2 the face a little bit of this little
bit of that back to the face face eros
to the face so you so for these guys you
want to trace like distract him with his
arrows yeah he's looking though oh no
that's hot lava no no damn it
can you position at Reyes oh no no
oh oh hey how are you Ghost of Sparta
yes big boy with an eye the big boy
what you got there big boy yeah what is
the whole thing is this uh so even as
our trolls I believe in like they have
there's they'll have this giant stone
and they like a warship stick reuse used
to worship this is my sound so my stall
and I use it no oh no oh my god the
truth is he's chillin he's a trooper oh
nice I can get around him a little
stagger there yeah
dang it can you take advantage of those
staggers at all yeah like I see yes a no
he's got you're tough like if they're
hurt it's it's hard to get up closer
[ __ ] but let's see if I can do it like I
want I need them to be distracted
and let that work yeah that's right
axe but
accident by
oh now like what's up
heck no god no oh nice a decapitation
he's dead now
yeah definitely dead now it definitely
does
you know it wouldn't be a brutal battle
working but I needs a capitation yeah
there's plenty of that
oh whoa can you not about you him him
also
Wow
hello video games yeah that's right next
exit angle damn it
oh yeah that move this guy I wanna play
- yeah oh here we go
is that it's done it [ __ ] oh but see no
no it's no it's not co-op it's a
single-player game I'm just I'm invested
get up I'm ready you're sitting there
not ready you're not ready it's I'm
curious to see if future guided workings
will explore different mythologies saw
somebody comment yeah that's a good
question right I like I like this take
on it though Norse mythology is it's
pretty uh it's pretty brutal I mean a
good setting for God of War you gotta go
something yeah yeah go somewhere after
killing Zeus right yeah I always thought
that Greek mythology was kind of like I
said it out there to Ben earlier but
very days of our lives it's very uh
ticking soap opera oh here we go oh nice
yeah I think
I like your sit down now yeah that was
awesome yeah that was cool that was that
was brutal bloody brutal badass things
you spectrum you gotta work in a fight
and I imagine they just get bigger from
there yeah that might actually be the
best time to end it yeah I think that's
a I think that's a high note I know that
after this not necessary spoilery but
that's a high note and that's gonna be
it for today
hello guys thank you for joining us when
they came now thank you for joining us
today to play some god of war uh on the
ps4 you know it was fun very fun thank
you for playing Rob yeah thanks for
having me if you guys want to check out
more god of war stuff we have the review
which is on youtube and also the history
got a war
jean-luc did it's awesome it goes into
the past stories so even if you haven't
played god of war
this game you can definitely jump into
and if you want some of the backstory
John Luke's breakdown just a really good
job on both like the the plot and the
gameplay and the development side of
things so that's really awesome check it
out yeah definitely um we're gonna be
doing more god of war streams so
tomorrow
Rob will be back with Erik yep 9 a.m.
there we playing some more specific um
mid to mid mid to late game yeah again
like kind of avoiding like main story
spoilers so be more like the big hub
area of this game that you will find a
lot of side activities side quests and
stuff so we'll be kind of looking at
that as well as like you know again mid
mid level skills and stuff like that a
you can expect out of this game yep and
there's gonna be more more gotta work
content coming out on this channel today
tomorrow and in the coming weeks yeah
absolutely
stay tuned yeah we always stream here at
from 11 to 11:30 we've game spot daily
coming up
they're gonna be doing a news rundown of
the biggest news stories of the day
mm-hmm with Kelly and Michael and every
day we normally stream from 11:00 11:30
to like one so if you're new here please
join us again yeah and yeah in just a
few moments if you stick around
gamespot daily we'll be starting but
other than that it's fine if yes if you
guys want a ps4 I think this is a must
to be honest it's very fun and I am
thoroughly enjoying it I think you guys
will too
all right thanks guys bye
you
you